>> Okay, so I'm going to make a double
2048. There's going to be one grid up here
and one grid down here and there's going to
be, it's just going to be a disaster of tiles.
>> All right, let's see what happens.
>> So, I'm going to copy everything from game container which is two levels in.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, I'm going to highlight down, and
then this is the closing div.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And it's two levels in, so I'm going to copy and
paste. Save it.
>> All right, let's see what happened.
>> Okay, so, here we are. Let's reload the page.
>> All right.
>> And, okay, whoa, [LAUGH] that is not what I wanted.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I was hoping that there would be way more tile
movement. But it looks like just the top tiles are going.
>> Yep.
>> That's unfortunate, but I guess I shouldn't
have expected too much. Any idea what happened here?
>> Not without looking at the code a little bit more.
>> All right, well, maybe we'll do that in lesson two.
>> All right.